this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
let's go ahead and start talking about
proteins a little bit about what they
are and why they're important first
thing is what are proteins
well proteins are polypeptides that and
of course probably peptides are just
long strings of amino acids connect the
pipe f dead bonds but their polypeptides
that specific we have folded into some
three-dimensional structure that serves
some function okay that's what a protein
is so proteins and polypeptides they're
both long strings of amino acids but
proteins are polypeptides that have
folded and taken on some sort of
functional role so if we think about a
string of amino acids we just have a
polypeptide so of each of these circles
represents an amino acid we have a bunch
of them connected to each other in a
long strand almost like a chain and it
folds takes on a certain structure that
has a function that is a protein and
we'll talk a little bit more about the
structural details later I want to give
a quick 3d visual representation of the
difference between a polypeptide and a
protein so here we've got a short
peptide it's specifically seven amino
acids long and if i zoom in here we can
actually go through and see the ncc
backbone right where each ncc of course
is an amino acid residue we can see if
we zoom in a little further specific
residues right like right in the middle
there that's faylene but this is
basically just a short peptide right
if we look over to the left we see that
the amino end over to the right we see
the carboxy end but this is just a
peptide right and of course because it's
seven to mean last as long but if we're
a lot longer it'd be a polypeptide but
it's not a protein into that polypeptide
folds upon itself takes on some sort of
structure and then some sort of
functional role a protein looks
something like this so this is a protein
it is specifically myoglobin and this is
a polypeptide chain a single polypeptide
chain that folded upon itself took on
this three-dimensional structure and
this 3d shape is functional right
myoglobin specific function is to
deliver oxygen muscle
excuse me oxygen to muscle tissue so you
can see that this sort of stick model
representation is very similar to that
at that
we just saw but of course it's a lot
longer and it's folded upon itself
sometimes it can be represented a little
bit differently instead of this ball and
stick model or shooting this stick model
it would have a sort of surface view and
look like this looks like kind of like a
glob right with with surfaces and that's
this is a globular shape and that term
globular will end up coming up and being
important later when we describe certain
different proteins okay so the next
question is kind of why do we care why
do we care about proteins how are they
important why are they important where
are they important and if you know
anything about proteins you know there's
like a gajillion places and reasons why
proteins are important there's a wrote
that here there are a gazillion places
to find proteins in our bodies and they
serve a variety of functions so speaking
of which let's talk about the major
functions of proteins so first thing is
catalysis catalysis of biochemical
reactions many proteins are enzymes
which in such a just biological
catalysts catalysts of course speed up
chemical reactions when those reactions
are biological reactions those catalysts
are then called enzymes and enzymes many
of them are proteins and so in fact
pretty much all of them are proteins an
example here we have a reaction
converting glucose in the glucose
6-phosphate is the first reaction of
glycolysis hexokinase is the enzyme that
catalyzes that reaction and XO kinase is
a protein okay so here is that actual
hexyl kinase protein is what actually
goes through and catalyzes the
conversion of glucose to glucose
6-phosphate and by applying this surface
simulation we can actually visualize the
hexokinase more as we typically think of
when we think of its globular structure
it also helps us visualize these little
pockets where we can zoom in here and
actually see the glucose 6-phosphate in
there and we can actually select that
glucose 6-phosphate and kind of pull it
out off of the protein out of that
little pocket so we'll select it go
through and
from the Protein and just go ahead and
pull it out and so now we could see
there this actual model has the glucose
and glucose 6-phosphate both in that
little pocket so we can zoom in here and
kind of take a closer look at that
glucose and glucose 6-phosphate
especially relative to the size of that
protein and it's worth noting that
nearly every single reaction that occurs
in our cells is catalyzed by some enzyme
and so what happens basically is that
you have some sort of substrate binding
an enzyme at its active site that little
site there where the substrate binds is
called the active site and then it
converts that substrate into a product
okay that's a very important function of
proteins the next thing is the binding
of molecules or the binding of ligands
and a ligand is just something that
binds something else that is bigger than
itself okay so for example hemoglobin is
a protein that binds oxygen so oxygen is
the ligand and it's got four different
four different subunits that make it up
hemoglobin of course is important and
binding oxygen and delivering oxygen
carrying oxygen through the blood and to
the tissues from the lungs okay
myoglobin is similar than that it also
binds a ligand that ligand is oxygen
it's it's only got one polypeptide unit
though and it's important it's functions
a little bit different it's important
delivering oxygen to the muscle tissues
here to the right we've got hemoglobin
and the smaller structure to the left is
myoglobin and both of these proteins
bind oxygen and you'll notice there's
similarity in structure with these
ribbons and that makes sense because
their functions are similar they both
bind oxygen
this colorful structure here is also
hemoglobin I just got four different
subunits of different colors we got pink
green red and blue and what I want to do
is take off one of these subunits we'll
take this pink one and we'll place it
next to myoglobin and taking a look at
it like this helps us visualize the
structural similarities right we can see
how these ribbons are arranged in a
similar
and that makes sense they both function
in binding oxygen so it makes sense that
they have these structural similarities
okay
another example of a protein that binds
some sort of ligand or some sort of
molecule we've got antibodies or
immunoglobulins so antibodies are these
immune proteins are sort of y-shaped and
those antibodies go through and bind
antigens and they're involved in the
immune system and that's about the
extent to which I want to talk about
that here okay another major function of
proteins is structural integrity or
structural support and so here we're
talking about proteins that don't
exactly play a role in helping a
reaction move forward they don't bind
anything specifically they just they're
just important in maintaining structure
okay so some examples here are collagen
keratin and elastin and these are all
fibrous proteins and when I think of a
fiber I think of like a rope okay and
collagen actually is is kind of like a
rope it's like it's a got a triple helix
looks something like this one two three
three sort of strands kind of like those
little pretzel twists here is a better
visual you can actually see the three
green spirals that actually make up that
triple helix the point is that it's long
and fibrous and it's it's meant to be
strong and just supportive structurally
collagen is is them is the main
component of connective tissue it shows
up in the ligaments tendons skin bone
cartilage and it's actually the most
abundant protein in mammals okay
keratin is also a component of
connective tissue it's important in the
hair and nails elastin is also a
component of connect this issue it's
what allows the skin to be stretchy okay
so next up another function is transport
across membranes so let's scroll this
down a bit here so the idea here is that
proteins can be involved in allowing
some sort of substances or actual
compounds from all
fuels to go from one side of a membrane
to one other side of the membrane and
that can happen in in a couple different
ways one of the way it can either happen
with channel proteins or with carrier
proteins both of these proteins are
shown in purple here and they're both
embedded in the membrane and here the
difference is that with channel proteins
you have molecules on one side and they
make make their way through the channel
protein because the channel proteins
basically like a tube alright so they
kind of just go and make their way
through the tube over to the other side
okay so they get from one side of the
membrane to the other by simply passing
through that - that is that channel
protein okay so here we have ATP
synthase which of course makes ATP and
the electron transport chain it's
embedded in the inner mitochondrial
membrane shown back there the membrane
bound component is the f0 subunit there
and the f1 subunit right there actually
makes the ATP from ADP so let's move
that membrane out of the way and take a
closer look at this protein up top here
we can actually see the f0 subunit is
very tube-like and it's actually an
example of a channel protein right we
can look right through this tube so what
happens is that protons flow from the
inter membrane space through this tube
back into the mitochondrial matrix they
just actually made their way right
through and that is coupled to the
phosphorylation of ADP to make ATP by
that f1 subunit down there
whereas carrier proteins they function a
little bit differently they will go
through and bind something on one side
of a membrane and then then the protein
will sort of change it's sort of
conformation and then spit them the the
particle out on the other side of the
membrane okay so here the particle
doesn't pass through the protein the
protein is not just a tube but it
actually gets carried across okay over
the other side this so both of these
types of proteins accomplish a similar
thing and that they're carrying or Sudi
I shouldn't say the word carry but they
they're both involved in taking
something from one side or allowing
something from one side of a membrane to
the other they just do it in different
ways
another thing is signal transduction and
this is kind of difficult to describe
here signal transduction is the idea
that
some signaling molecule or some signal
like this little orange guy here can can
show up on basically the outside of a
cell and bind a membrane protein and
then cause some sort of cellular
response on the inside of the cell now
this involves a multitude of proteins
right here we have a gpcr which is
stands for our g-protein coupled
receptor in purple and over here this is
the cheap protein which has multiple
subunits when it gets activated it can
stimulate the activity of an effector
effector enzyme that can trigger a whole
cascade of different things to happen
and many of those things that happen
involve proteins so and ultimately
there's some sort of cellular response
but the point is that in making it so a
signal is transduced from the outside to
the inside of a cell that involves many
proteins okay and last but certainly not
least is movement so we're talking about
moving within a cell across or involving
microtubules tubulin is important for
talking about muscular movement we're
talking about actin and myosin also
dying in and kind Nissen are important
when it comes to movement there's just a
bunch of different proteins and a bunch
of different structures and a bunch of
different functions okay the theme
basically is that structure determines
function I hope that video is helpful
thanks for watching